- I growed up.
I was way into years.
We had a outside toilet.
We drawed water out of the well.
We milked cows.
We growed up tough, but we made it.
- [Mark] All right, Randy.
- [Randy] Yes.
Randy, where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- I'm from eastern Kentucky,
right here in this old holler.
Spurlock Fort, Dana, Kentucky.
- [Mark] This is Floyd County.
- This is Floyd County, yes, it is.
I grew up out here on the old farm.
- [Mark] Tell me, tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents, growing up?
- Yes, I had my mother and daddy.
Johnny Acres and Margie
Acres was my mom and dad.
We growed up, they was seven children.
We didn't have any running water.
We didn't have no bathroom in the house.
We drawed water for mom to wash clothes
on old wringer washer.
Dad worked in the coal
mine from daylight to dark.
He raised us here on the farm.
He raised what we eat.
He raised hogs, chicken, cattle.
We plowed the old garden
with the old mule.
Me and my brother, when we got old enough,
we plowed, we hoed, we
took care of the farm
while dad worked.
Mom, she was a housewife.
She took care of the house and
all the washing and cleaning.
We grew up poor,
but you know that was the best life
we ever had growing up because
we knowed what it meant
to live.
You had to work, you
had to raise your food.
You couldn't run to the store and buy it.
And when we got up in
the, way up in the years,
I remember we got some running
water in the old house.
Oh, that was the best
thing ever happened to us
was running water.
Then they pitched in and
they built mom a bathroom.
That tickled my mom to death
because she was never
had nothing like that.
- [Mark] You had an
outhouse up until then?
- We had an outhouse, yes.
We called it the old toilet.
- [Mark] And what is an outhouse?
It's just a place that
you go to the bathroom
and then the water, the waste.
- The water over it,
the water you build it
over the creek or a
stream is what I call it.
- [Mark] So the waste goes into the creek?
- The waste went in the creek.
And as time grew, you
know, things was different.
I remember having an
old TV line up the hill.
You got one channel, Channel Three.
We would go to school during the day,
we'd come home in the evening,
that's the first thing we'd do
is hit that hill to turn that antennae
so we can watch Channel Three.
That's all we had.
And as time went on,
they finally got TV cable
and phone, and all that stuff.
I remember the first phone they ever had
was called a party line.
You had to get on it first,
because if you didn't,
you didn't get to talk.
As time got farther along,
dad had to quit work.
You know, there for
years we struggled again.
But, you know, I can thank God.
He took care of us.
He kept us all together as our family.
We worked hard, but until
today I still work hard.
I keep my condition
going as my dad asked me.
"Son, keep buying hogs, killings hogs,
"raise your family right."
I've raised three daughters
pretty well on my own.
I'm well satisfied with
the way they turned out.
- [Mark] With your wife?
- No, no, I divorced my
wife, I raised my kids.
- [Mark] By yourself?
- By myself.
Which my sister, and my,
their niece, my niece,
they helped me raise them girls.
But we raised all three of them.
By now, they know what it means to live.
I try to keep things just
the way that dad had it
back when I growed up.
- [Mark] So why did, why did
the mom not keep the kids?
That's typically how it goes, right?
- Well, basically because
the mom got on drugs.
- [Mark] Oh.
- And you know, that's
one thing I don't do.
Yes, I've had four back surgeries.
I'm the first to tell you,
but you never turn to drugs
because drugs will kill you.
- [Mark] That's how the
drugs kind of took hold here
in this region?
- I have lost a lot of my best friends
that I went to school
with on account of that.
And you know, I will not turn to that.
I, like I said, I've
had four back surgeries.
I thank God every day
that I still make it.
And I don't have to rely.
Yes, I hurt.
But you got to go on with your life.
I tell my daughter,
they work all the time.
The main thing is to take care of yourself
and make sure that you got food to eat.
Because you know, as the old saying,
we not going to be here all
the time to protect them
and take care of them.
My daughter lives with me now.
She stays here, but she can kill hogs.
She can kill chickens
just as good as I can,
because I've taught her that.
My other daughter, she lives in Georgetown
and I don't see her as much
as I like to, you know,
but you've got to go where you can work.
The work population here is way down.
- [Mark] What kind of jobs
that you've had in your life?
- I've been a coal miner
all my life, mister.
I worked all my life in the coal mines.
And I have really done well,
you know, but I got four,
had four back surgeries, like
I said, and I keep going.
I tend my garden just like I always did.
But I'd like, love to go back
and plow the garden
with the old horse or the
old mule like we used to.
But anymore its all about
a rototiller and a tractor.
But I'd like to get away from
that and go back to that way
I was raised up doing it.
- [Mark] Pretty simple.
- Because it was a lot
better back then, I thought.
You know, we worked hard.
I growed up, I worked all my life.
When I was a young kid, I worked.
And all my brothers and my
sister, they worked, too.
- [Mark] How far do you go in school?
- I graduated from high
school at Betsy Layne.
I went down here to the
old Prater School to the,
and graduated down there,
I guess from eighth grade.
And then we had to go to Betsy Layne,
but they closed that
old Prater School down
down there now.
- [Mark] What do you think
it is about Appalachia
that makes people here so special?
Is it the struggle?
The hard, the hard?
- I believe it's a struggle.
You know, people in this
area, they work together.
If I do something, my neighbors help me.
If they do something, I go help them.
Me and my two buddies down
the road, yes, we raise corn.
We plant it by hand
and we pick it by hand.
But that's how we was raised
up doing stuff like that.
And you know, like I said,
I enjoy doing that stuff.
And,
you know, I just,
I just wish we could go back
and do things different,
you know, growing up.
But, you know, that was the good days.
We couldn't change
anything if we wanted to.
That's how it was meant to be.
- [Mark] Do you think all this technology
and all the advancements in the world
have set us off on the wrong course?
- Yeah, I think so.
I think, you know, it's,
nothing personally,
but I think when they went to cell phones
and computer stuff, that's
when things went down.
You know, I could be wrong, I don't know.
But that's just my belief.
I don't own a cell phone.
I don't own a computer
because in my knowledge,
I don't know how to work stuff like that.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 60 years old.
- [Mark] Sixty.
What was the best part of your life?
The best time of your life?
- Growing up.
- [Mark] As a kid?
- Growing up as a kid
and helping kill hogs,
kill chicken, calves, whatever.
That's how we grow, and raise our garden,
can our canned food,
and raise our potatoes.
That was my best days of my life.
Growing up with all my, with
my mom and dad and my brother
and brothers and my sister.
That that was the good days.
And you know, me and my
family is still close.
Me and my brother, my sister,
we're still real close.
- [Mark] You'd describe yourself as happy?
- Oh, yes, yes.
- [Mark] You said you seem to be.
- Yes, I'm happy.
- [Mark] Have you ever left?
- No, I've never left Kentucky here, no.
I, you know, I've been on vacation visits,
but I always want to
come home to Kentucky.
- [Mark] What happens when
you leave eastern Kentucky?
Do you?
- I miss it.
It's always, I'm wanting to get home.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Because there's no place
like home is my saying.
- [Mark] What are the worst
parts about living here?
- Well.
- [Mark] I mean, did
you, did you have a car
when you were a kid?
- No, no, no.
We didn't.
I was probably 16 years old
when I first got my first bicycle.
I was probably, no.
- [Mark] And how would
your parents get around
or how would you get around?
- Well, my dad had an old
truck that he drove to work.
That's how, if we went anywhere,
we all got in the back and
went in the back of the truck.
- [Mark] That was when you were 16 though?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But I'm saying before that.
- [Randy] Well, that's
how we got around then.
Or we walked or we rode a horse.
- [Mark] That's what I'm saying, yeah.
- [Randy] Yeah.
- [Mark] So if you didn't have a car,
you were using a horse.
- [Randy] Yeah, yeah.
- [Randy] But that was the good days.
- [Mark] Are you religious?
- [Randy] I go to church, yes, some.
But not like I should.
- [Mark] And you have friends?
- [Randy] Oh, yes, I
got oodlings of friends.
- [Mark] Yeah?
What are you proudest of?
- [Randy] Well, just growing
up and seeing my kids grow up.
- [Mark] Your kids are doing well?
- [Randy] Oh, yes.
They real, they do real good.
Yeah, all three of them.
All three girls.
And they do excellent.
I'm really proud of them,
how they've growed up.
- [Mark] That's great.
- [Randy] But they've been
taught to grow up this way.
- [Mark] Yeah, you set a good role model.
- [Randy] Huh?
- [Mark] You were a good role model.
- [Randy] Yes, everybody tells me that.
They, a lot of my buddies tell me,
"You've done great raising them."
You know, when I was a young man,
I wanted to go out here and do stuff.
But I had a responsibility - kids.
That was my responsibility.
And I took care of them.
- [Mark] Do you have any regrets in life?
- [Randy] Not really.
I just, you know, I enjoyed life
because you don't know if
it's today or tomorrow,
you don't know when life's over,
just, you know, you got to
be ready when it's over.
- [Mark] And then the poverty
you've endured as a child
was kind of across the board.
Everybody in this region
is in the same boat.
- Right.
- [Mark] So you didn't
really feel poor, did you?
- No, no.
We was all just alike.
I tell my kids about today.
We growed up.
If you got a pop, it
was a special occasion,
because they didn't have money to buy it.
We, me and my brother,
we milked cows.
That's how we got our
milk for many, many years.
And we, you know, like I
said, we had our own chickens,
we milked our own cows.
We done it all.
That's how we growed up.
That's what make you
respect life, you know,
how you growed up.
- [Mark] And tell me about
working as a coal miner.
I mean that, that's a
very rough job, right?
Dangerous?
- Well, it's very dangerous.
I worked six days a week,
10, 12, 14 hours a day
since I, when I turned 18 years old.
I went to work in the coal mines
because that's all they was.
- [Mark] There were no other options.
- No other options.
And I worked many, many
years for the same company.
Like I said, it's about
three, four miles from here,
you know?
But it was a great job.
It was great people to work for.
They treated you with respect.
You know, I'm sure we made
them millions of dollars
but that's what we was there for.
- [Mark] It kept the whole region alive?
- Oh, yes, yes.
- [Mark] It's afforded all the businesses,
all the everything.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And now that that's dried up.
- We had two little grocery
stores here on the creek
when I growed up and went
to grade school down here.
You could go and eat lunch there.
They didn't have a lunch
room at our grade school.
You'd eat lunch.
Mom and dad had a credit set up.
You'd get 35 cents worth of stuff.
But a lot of time for 35 cents,
you couldn't eat everything you got.
Now you can't get a pop for 35 cents.
You know, times has changed.
- [Mark] Yeah, but the, but the, your,
the income for this region
is pretty much the same
as it's been back in the late '70s.
People don't, people
aren't making more money
and yet everything costs more.
- True, very true.
You don't make a lot more
money this day and time
because it takes a lot more to live.
- [Mark] And a lot of people
are living off the government.
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] Because there's
no coal mining jobs
and there's no other options, right?
What do you worry about?
- Well, I don't worry about anything.
You know, I love to see
my two grandkids raised.
But I know they got a fine mom and dad.
I know they will raise
them and take care of them.
- [Mark] And what do your
daughters do for work?
- They work for RoadSafe.
- [Mark] Which is what?
- Its a traffic system, they
flag for the power company.
- [Mark] Okay.
And where's your ex-wife
after she got involved in drugs?
- I guess she's on Toler.
I don't, I don't have no
associations with them.
- [Mark] She's on what?
- She lives on Toler Creek, they call it
and, but I have no association with her.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned
in your life?
- Well, how times, how hard times get.
You know, times get hard sometimes.
But you know, like I said, here
on the farm, we do our hogs.
We do our chickens.
We can live a long time,
but people would have to
go to the store to get their next meal.
I don't know what's going to happen
but you got to keep going on and on
because life goes on.
You know, you struggle for something,
it'll get better as time
goes, it'll get better.
I just thank God that we've
got enough we can live.
(rooster crowing)
- [Mark] All right,
Randy, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you for coming.
- [Mark] And good luck
with your daughters,
and your, the rest of your life.
- And I want you to come
back, if it's just a visit
when we kill hogs.
I'll welcome you to come back
and eat some fresh hog meat
on the old coal fire and enjoy with us.
- [Mark] I'd love that.
- [Randy] You don't have to family.
I mean, you're welcome to come back
and just sit around and
enjoy the food with us.
(rooster crowing)
- [Mark] That sounds wonderful.
Thank you so much.
- [Randy] Thank you for coming.
- [Mark] All right, Randy,
thank you very much.
- [Randy] Thank you.
- [Mark] All right.